ladies and gentlemen my name is ryan
wright and my name is jerry welcome to
our show it is called reasons to see
today we're going to do something a
little different you see there's a
director out there
a very famous director
who some of you probably have never
heard of his name is james wan nope not
bond juan in case you guys i know you
direct a film such as insidious
the conjuring
what else do you do jerry did silence uh
death sentence saw is probably the
biggest one i like how you named off as
two
least liked films first i went reverse
order
yeah you know
in cities two the conjuring insidious
death sentence dead silence saw one he
said something the other day that really
really broke my heart he said he's going
to be retiring from acting wait wrong
sentence he said he's going to be
retiring from directing
not directing all together he's a horror
movie he said he's gonna retire from
directing horror movies yeah directing
horror movies sorry i should have
finished that sentence yeah so
that's what we're going to talk about
today
is this still the intro i think so
maybe we should do a new intro this is a
really meandering intro i'm okay with it
all right
this is really sad because he says he's
gonna stop directing horror movies and
don't get me wrong the last two movies
of this franchise has has been great but
the fact that his next movie is going to
be the next fast and furious film as
like i'll show you guys i can do more
than horror it's like no what
why
why that choice then i think it's
awesome he's doing it fast and furious
seven my one
issue is that this is supposed to be
like his next step his next big mark
what is a transition you know because i
mean horror is kind of the bastard genre
of you know popular cinema i get the the
idea because he's making the transition
in a successful franchise that's likely
to make lots of money so it's not
like he's stepping out of the box and
making a great film necessarily but i
think it's a smart choice in the sense
that he will probably get work after
fast and furious seven regardless no i i
don't doubt that it's gonna be awesome
like but something about me i i'm just a
little concerned that's not going to
have that like some signature james
wants stamp to it but who knows maybe he
will blow my mind away you know like
skyfall blew everyone's mind away
whenever that sam mendes was directing
disappear like sam mendes a bond movie
and it was [ __ ] incredible that bond
movie i don't know how
those producers run their franchise
because i don't know if it's gonna be
like something along the lines of like a
csi show where it's like even if you're
a cool guest director they're not gonna
change the formula so much for you or if
it's going to be like yeah james one put
your spin on it that's what i'm
concerned about is is him not having his
freedom because he's worked with
independent films uh for like his whole
career pretty much and now he's hopping
onto like universal studios biggest
[ __ ] movie apparently yeah and isn't
that weird how that's like their biggest
one i thought they had other movies i
thought jurassic park was a bigger movie
i don't know i i i can't see those are
probably the biggest franchises or so
many of them i can never tell in terms
of money it's like it always there's
always a way to argue about how
inflation or tickets or like what kind
of tickets people are buying i can never
fully wrap my mind around those
calculations but apparently fast six is
their biggest movie i can sort of get
down with what he said because he said
kind of what rob zombie said basically
he said he wanted to retire from horror
because he doesn't want to get
pigeonholed as the horror guy he said he
loves all branches of cinema and he
wants to branch out it's like the same
thing with rob zombie do i think he'll
never do a horror movie again no i think
he probably will but somewhere down the
road i notice all filmmakers are like
michael jordan they all they constantly
say they're retiring but they never do
well how do you visit people how do you
retire from art you know yeah that
doesn't make any sense like when stephen
soderbergh was like i'm not gonna make
movie what
really
don't believe you buddy i'll see you in
a few years really yeah it seems like
like code four i'm gonna take an
extended vacation and i can understand
it's like they probably do think that
they're retiring like you know in
stephen soderbergh's case i'm sure he
does plan to retire but you know you get
away from something for a long enough
period of time you know you never know
how you might feel differently you know
it's a weird thing even though i i
brought up how i first felt as we've
been talking i suddenly have all these
other different feelings about like the
fact that james juan made that statement
like it's so cool to see because this
guy has progressed so much as a director
go on like rotten tomatoes and watch
progression happen he didn't saw that he
was like he's finding his group i'm not
i don't base my opinion off of like
rotten tomatoes says or anything because
i happen to enjoy like death it was like
a lot of people and especially lately
i've heard people say did that they
really enjoyed death that sentence is
cool and uh dead silence is really cool
too to me i enjoy these movies that a
lot of critics hate so yeah and i know
that the dead silence was a very hard
movie to make in terms of their
interaction with the studio because that
was going from saw which was an
independent film to you know a universal
studios pictures sequel uh not sequel
you know to a big studio movie and then
after that he went back to independent
for a while we'll see how he does back
on the big scale this guy knows how to
do stories with character he knows how
to do genre films too with character the
genres are so defined in his films yeah
and i love that about them you know i
think he said that in one of his
interviews that he specific he really
likes to work within genres and so i'm
excited for his take on on the next fast
and furious but i'm also excited to see
what original content he'll be able to
do like especially now that he'll get a
lot more money and stuff i can't wait to
see how creative his mind will get you
know because i think he's capable of
doing more than horror like if you watch
the conjuring it's like a drama that
happens to be a horror film at the same
time and it's a damn good drama well
yeah and i mean he's got a definite
sense for visuals he's got a style you
know and i think he can bring a lot to a
lot of other different genres and i mean
selfishly i hope he does more
collaborations with lee 1l just because
i like the way they jive off each other
and i've heard lee when i'll say that
they've been working on a sci-fi project
so maybe that'll come to a light soon
every time i've seen him talk it just
seems like he's really
just passionate about movies in general
he's british or something he's
australian australian both of those guys
are from australia that is [ __ ] nuts
because i have only seen pictures of
that guy in interviews on collider.com
and stuff i heard one interview of him
like yesterday and i was like holy
mother of god you have a completely
different voice than i imagine you don't
have because james juan and lee wanna i
think they like flew out from australia
to do the meetings about saw and stuff
like that and they made like a short
back there that's cool so yeah good for
good for james wan yeah
proud of you james
mean
juan
juan
sorry i don't know what that was
racism that's how i thought james bond
would sound i mean i like
i made the movie saw
change hall cut your leg off
i'm just gonna watch you do this okay
let's see what else i could come up with
do an australian accent next oh yeah no
it's not funny with the australian
and then i'll go into my crocodile
dundee impression there you go i'm sure
somebody's offended yeah
i'm sure one of our viewers is a fan of
crocodile dundee well yeah or australian
or
australian
there's a man named australian out there
not at all i'm saying we're one of our
viewers is australia oh that's what you
mean
okay
oh we have we have lost track of the
conversation yeah a little bit james won
we're done alright guys thanks for
checking out our whatever we did for
james one here why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
us what you think about james wan
retiring from horror films yeah and then
once you're done with that come over
here and click this button so you can
see more episodes of reasons to see and
once you're done watching more episodes
of reasons to see click this button to
like us on facebook yeah
and click this button to follow us on
twitter
sweet yeah then once you're done with
all that you're going to want to get
updated every time a new review or a
video is out if you're a fan so
subscribe
james bond must get so much punani with
that voice do you know what i mean
yeah
i that's
like i think about being a fan of that
slang term for some reason well i didn't
want to say [ __ ] that sounded more a
vulgar
i guess i i guess i get your logic
i don't know this is something that this
seems kind of icky about it about punani
yeah a little bit i'm just like that
doesn't sound
attractive it sounds like a
one of those like asian chocolates
a little bit oh yeah yeah
james one would you like some punati
oh no
no no no no no james i hope james one
never watches this i do too i do hope he
doesn't watch this ever
because i really respect the guy i'm a
big fan i would love to work with him
and i would hate to think this is going
to jeopardize my chances
yeah i i know how you feel i know you
feel i want to i want to still be able
to attend these movies
i know i'm sure i'm sure you can still
watch them yeah because i don't want to
work with you because you didn't watch
universal needs
yeah
but apparently vin diesel skyrocketed
right now hey man diesel's back in
action
i know yeah dude this was the [ __ ] like
he was gonna be seeing james wong
working with all those actors i can't
wait to see his take on it that's gonna
be [ __ ] sweet yeah it's gonna be
like someone's a ghost
yeah in the race
racing with ghosts that's cool people
will have hallucinations of demons in
the driver's seat next to them yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna hallucinate jesus
christ that's what they should do with
insidious three bring jesus christ into
it
how cool would that be
that would be pretty cool
that would be weird that would be
awesome i know weird is good it'd be a
fight between good versus evil it'd be
like uh what's that russian movie called
night watcher night watch night watch
have you watched that yet yeah i saw
like the first 30 minutes i started just
yesterday no you didn't i promise you
really i know cause you bought it for me
and i was gonna do a review on it on my
other show straight to the point
and
i uh i didn't finish it because a friend
came over you really started watching
that watch yesterday yeah it's right
there you just happened to stack it
underneath all those other dvds no this
is moving stuff man all right all right
i love you jared i love you too ryan
right
you